[Music]
when it comes to body language it's
never an exact art and the things I'm
going to suggest they're all guidelines
but that said there are some certain
things that as a poker player I'll look
for and the most important thing is
first of all to get sort of a baseline
of somebody it's impossible to to tell
whether the behavior someone's showing
is meaningful or not if you don't know
how they naturally behave so the first
thing I'll do when I sit down at the
table is look at what my opponents are
doing when they're not in a hand you
know are they naturally quite gregarious
oh they confidence you know when they
interact with the waitress or are they
naturally quite quiet and shy how do
they how do they sit are they are they
naturally closed off are they very
languishing that kind of thing and it
must have got an idea of their baseline
outside of a hand then I looked to see
how they deviate from that when they're
actually in the middle of playing or you
know in a tense situation and in general
what you want to look for in both poker
but also when you're to say trying to
figure out if someone's lying is there
their comfort level if if there's sort
of if they seem authentic like as a rule
of thumb humans are actually quite good
picking up authenticity if someone's
being disingenuous so that's that's sort
of the thing to look out for and there
are some like classic behaviors that
I've noticed people do at the table
where they'll they'll sort of make a
point of if you see them something
making a point of making themselves
bigger you know they wear their
naturally sitting like this and now
they're sort of puffing up ah that's
more often than not sort of false
confidence that they're trying to show
you know most people do try to stay very
constant so if you notice sort of like
you really do notice a behavior
particularly against someone who seems
to play quite regularly their chances
are they're they're aware of their
behavior so they're probably trying to
mislead you
but another rule of thumb I like to
follow is the first thing you learn as a
kid usually to when you lie is Oh Liars
won't look you in the eye so what to
pick what the kids do to overcompensate
they'll look you in the eye and
similarly people are very aware of their
faces and you know this part of their
body if they're trying to be dishonest
but what they're not thinking about is
the rest of their body so the lower down
on the body that you're looking at the
more reliable the information is so if
you think about when you're excited
about something generally speaking you
want pounce around and and and before
some of you can't keep still and you
know that's like we call it Happy Feet
in poker like the the feet are often the
most reliable thing to look at on your
opponent because they might be
completely stoic in their face but their
feet are bouncing around it's usually a
sign that they have a really strong hand
but similarly if they're sort of smiling
and chatty but their feet FL all of a
sudden sort of tucked themselves around
the table that we were you know around
the chair legs something's up there so
as a rule of thumb look for the rest of
someone else's body more than their face
if you're trying to figure out if
they're telling you the truth or not
[Music]